Glanz und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus ich bin so wahnsinnig gut
genau merkst dass der Sommer ne es ist
Sommer ich geht dir das auch so je älter
man wird desto sommeraffiner wird mein
Gefühl früher war ich immer in der Kälte
unterwegs ich habe was Gefühl die Haut
noch du reißt doch auch in Geld ja ja
das erzähle ich immer aber Wahrheit ähm
darüber
gemütlich und mir neulich neulich eine
Dermatologin gesagt ja wissen Sie Ihre
Haut wird immer dünner und deswegen sind
sie dann so kälteempfindlich geworden
und ich ich möchte das was dran ich
glaube es geht los ich bin jetzt im
Bereich permanent Richard Sommer und wir
haben ein bisschen Zeit über Themen zu
reden über die man sonst eigentlich
nicht redet und speziell über ein Thema
redet man in Deutschland insbesondere
gar nicht über das Thema Geld und genau
deswegen finde ich sollten heute mal
über Geld reden okay du weißt dass man
uns dafür öffentlich hinrichten
wie also zwei gute wesentlichen
studieren über Geld aber lass uns das
doch direkt abräumen also um um dein
Geld um mein Geld soll es heute nicht
gehen aber lass uns so offen wie es wie
es notwendig ist darüber sprechen also
ich habe keinen sehr verkrampftes
Verhältnis zu Geld sondern im Gegenteil
ich finde Geld ist eine in Wahrheit eine
gute Sache und wenn Leute mal sagen geld
macht nicht glücklich dann kann ich aus
meinem Leben berichten relativ
verbindlich sagen unglücklich aber auch
nicht also dieses Gefühl dass die Karte
mit Sicherheit wieder aus dem
Geldautomaten rauskommt ja jetzt habe
ich einige Jahre nicht gehabt ich auch
nicht ne also ein paar Jahre das
Geräusch das entsteht wenn diese Karte
ja wenn ihr nicht mehr rauskommt richtig
genau alles du lass mal das Erlebnis ich
hatte das Ergebnis zweimal und nicht
ganz häufig habe ich gebetet und es hat
geholfen also ich sicher war die Karte
kommt nicht raus aber sie kam irgendwie
raus
kam auch Geld raus ich meine mich zu
erinnern das Geld rauskamen ja ja ich
hatte das gar nicht schon so oft schon
Geldautomaten es kam nichts raus und ich
hatte wirklich mehrfach dann das
Erlebnis dann diese dieses Geräusch da
kommt so ein kurzes trockenes Geräusch
und das Ding weg schmatzt ja und dann
kommt die in lauter geschreddert in
lauter kleinen wieder raus die kann gar
nicht mehr raus und das schlimmer als
die Tatsache dass dieser Geldautomat
einfach die Karte verspeist hat war das
Gefühl danach also mit welchem
Gesichtsausdruck drehst du dich um zu
den hinter dir wartenden und versuchst
irgendwie zu erklären dass das jetzt
einfach nur ein Fehler der Maschine
genau alle anderen mit missionarischem
Alter davon überzeugen dass der
Geldautomat kaputt ist richtig und ich
ich drehte mich immer um und murmelte so
versteht das gar nicht man konnte es ja
nicht gedeckt und so und wusste schon
wie im hinausgehen kein Mensch wird mir
diese Notlüge glauben ich habe das immer
als wahnsinnig die demütigend empfunden
kein Geld zu haben dass das
stigmatisiert ein kein Geld zu haben und
das macht auch die definitiv unglücklich
ne also das ist schlechte schlechte
Träume schlechtes Einschlafen bitte
feste sorgen Leute die keine Angst haben
dass dein Telefon gesperrt wird und so
weiter Leute die kein Geld haben haben
ein hartes Leben und noch schlimmer
Kinder die Kinder von Eltern sind die
kein Geld haben das ist so hart weil
diese Hilflosigkeit die daraus entsteht
die ist allumfassen die geht in alle
Bereiche rein ne wenn du du bist als
Erwachsener hast du vielleicht immer
noch die Möglichkeit irgendetwas zu
machen irgendetwas zu drehen vielleicht
bist Du Chico der plötzlich 10 Millionen
im Lotto gewinnt oder so der mir
übrigens sehr sympathisch ist die Art
und Weise einer der großen gegenwartung
über die Kollegen reden
aber wenn du wenn du Kind bist bist du
so unvorstellbar hilflos und dein ganzes
Leben und ich habe das wirklich so
erlebt besteht darin sozusagen Techniken
zu entwickeln ja Taktiken zu entwickeln
um zu verdecken dass du einfach kein
Geld hast ja trägst die immer gleich ja
du hast das immer gleiche Schuhe
Zugehörigkeit und du hast diesen Makel
wie eine Sünde die jederzeit auffliegen
kann
genau das kommt
aus irgendeinem Grund und so weiter ja
bin gerade krank geworden und so das ist
wirklich hart aber weißt du was ich
interessant finde ich ja um kurzhalter
zu werden Geld ist auch ein schönes
Thema es stimmt es dass du mal bei Wer
wird Millionär warst ja das wird
wirklich
ein Foto von mir von damals wo ich also
Aussehen auf der Durchreise wirklich ja
geistert im Netz ja mal gucken also Juba
Wer wird Millionär 201
weil ich Geld brauchte
ganz simple Motiv heraus es war übrigens
interessant ich habe das dann später
auch mal öffentlich erzählt daraus wurde
und wieder macht Recht hatte
Steuerschulden und so war das natürlich
nicht ich hatte keine Steuerschulden in
dem Sinne sondern einmal im Jahr kommt
die Steuernachzahlung das heute noch so
so diese Steuernachzahlung würde sich da
mal so auf sechs bis 7000 DM berufen und
ähm
da die hatte ich aber vielleicht nur so
ganz ganz ganz so eben und dann dachte
ich gehe mal zu Wer wird Millionär ist
das gut ich sehe hier dieses Foto von
dir das ist ihre es gibt Fotos da siehst
aus wie ein Sonnen junger auch Hollywood
Schönling ja und dann geht's aber eine
andere Einstellung da bist du irgendwie
so eine Mischung aus
Hollywood und Klaus Kinski so ein leicht
würde ich auch sagen also irgendjemand
hat mal gesagt ich würde aussehen wie
diese Vampir Darsteller
und und
das war auch so dass die Darsteller weg
du siehst einfach
früher ganz häufig an ihrem Blick
attestiert wurde
letzten zehn Jahren keiner mehr gemacht
habe
sowas verwegenes hast du doch auf diesem
Erfolg
als hätte man sich nicht mehr alle auf
der Latte also das trifft den
Gesichtsausdruck bei diesem Wer wird
Millionär wurde in dem Moment weil ich
kann dir sagen welche Moment das Foto
gemacht wurde das muss man dazu sagen
weil ich bin ja nicht auf den Stuhl
gekommen okay du hast nein ich meine ich
habe gesagt in der ersten Runde und ich
kann ja auch erzählen wieso es ist
nämlich so was der normale Zuschauer
nicht weiß könnte ja auch wettet oder
damals jedenfalls hat er das gemacht
Formel mit dem Studio Leiter um einen 5
€ schein ja wie viele Kandidaten wie
hätten diese Eingangsfrage Wissen okay
das ist eine Hilfe
weil wenn sie sagen alle dann weißt du
du musst schnell sein ja okay und wenn
die sagen oh das weiß keiner dann weißt
du kannst
eine kleine Hilfe
und sagten das kann kein Mensch und dann
habe ich gedacht okay mal gucken was
kommt ja und dann kam ich musste vier
Ereignisse der 80er Jahre in die
richtige Reihenfolge bringen da muss man
sagen das war für mich extrem günstig
oder ist das gerne versuchen und dann
gucke ich auf die Uhr ja ich sag jetzt
also schnell die vier Dinge
Tschernobyl
kiesling-affäre und Matthias russlandet
auf dem Roten Platz oh Gott okay ich bin
raus ich weiß anfing habe ich
hingekriegt auch noch relativ
überschaubaren Zeit ich habe ein
bisschen Zeit genommen ich war mir aber
sicher dass ich das weiß also Kieslinger
Fähre Attentat auf Ranger dann Kiesling
Affäre war ja gleich nach dem Anfang der
neuen Regierung ja also 82 83 Attentat
auf Dragon war schon 80 81 oder so ja
das weiß ich noch
8667 parallel ungefähr zur
barsche-affäre Matthias
Rust in Moskau habe ich gesagt ja ja
immer hoch geflogen ja genau
so also habe ich ihn gekriegt und so
weiter und war ein stolzer Erwartung auf
den Schuld zu springen und tatsächlich
kein anderer hatte das bis auf einen und
der hatte das in 4 Sekunden ich habe ihn
dann nachher gefragt wie kann man das in
vier Sekunden wissen und er sagte ich
wusste es nicht
irgendein Kombination
ist Mathematiker werden das ausrechnen
können nicht so besonders lustig aber
der hat damit gerockt
ich bin nicht auf den Schul gekommen und
ich bin da und guck völlig verdutzt und
verstehe die Welt nicht mehr und da
drückt dieser dpa mal ab ja und dadurch
ist dieses Foto entstanden ja weißt du
ich habe es jetzt wie du aussiehst weißt
du wie du aussiehst du siehst aus wie
Jack Nicholson in scheint nein nein nein
nein ich ich sah nicht ansatzweise mein
Leben hier so männlich aus aber so wie
wie wie wie also ihre kann man
vielleicht sagen
vollkommen Ehre es werden jetzt
Millionen Menschen werden jetzt diese
dieses Foto mit diesem wunderbaren
rosafarbenen Hemd mit den langen spitzen
ich muss zu meiner Verteidigung sagen
das war damals in diese Haare diese
ja diese Haare waren mit diesem diesen
komischen Scheitel sind ja jetzt wieder
in nee da vorne
raus geföhnt wie wie so eine eigentlich
wie so eine wie so eine Dame ja genau
eine haarige Schirmmütze genau
Thema mal verkürzen weil es ist jetzt
nicht das schönste Foto von mir das ist
hier ich finde ja immer die Frage wer
wird Millionär wird ja allabendlich
gleich beantwortet nämlich im Zweifel
immer Günther Jauch auch kennst dieses
du kennst dieses herrliche Interview von
Günther Jauch schöne Grüße an der Stelle
das finde ich einen so großartigen
interviewschnipsel wo er gefragt wird so
so pseudo-industativ sagen sie ja auch
wenn Sie eine Million gewinnen würden
was würden sie dann damit machen und er
den kurz nach lacht sich kaputt und sagt
zu den anderen legen
so ehrlich ist er gewesen
ja Geld ganz grundsätzlich weißt du was
ich so interessant finde und ich habe es
ehrlich gesagt immer schon vermutet es
gab doch lange Zeit auch in der
Soziologie und so weiter immer diese
These und ich hatte immer das Gefühl da
werden nur Typen wie ich die kein Geld
hatten damals verarscht da wurde immer
erzählt mit ganz Bedeutung Schwangeren
Gesicht von Soziologen naja wissen Sie
mehr Geld macht er dann auch nicht
unbedingt glücklicher da gibt es diese
Grenze irgendwo bei 60 70.000 und dann
sind so die Grundbedürfnisse so gedeckt
und dann ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung
und alles was darüber hinauskommt
steigert nicht mehr Sieg nicht wie Kant
das Glücksempfinden der Leute und ich
dachte damals schon immer was ist das
für ein Hokuspokus den wir uns da
erzählen jetzt stellt sich raus DWI
Studie und total interessant sehr viel
Geld macht natürlich doch glücklich ja
darüber geschrieben in der Zeit ähm vor
ein paar Jahren stellst also die alte
these die lautet ja ja dass das das
Glück ziemlich steil ansteigt mit dem
Geld ja wenn du aber und da kommst nicht
auf die Zahl 60 70.000 an wenn du über
dem Durchschnitt des Landes in dem du
lebst und der Umgebung in der du nicht
also die Relation sozusagen genau die
Relation ist entscheidend von da an
steigt das Glück nicht mehr so steil an
dann wird die Kurve deutlich schwächer
das ist eigentlich der klassische Befund
und jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht ganz
falsch also 60 000 wird das Glück auf
okay ich habe immer gedacht ich nehme
auch diese flachere Kurve ich nehme sie
beide es ist völlig okay erst die ganz
steile und dann die etwas weniger steil
ist völlig okay und es gibt einen ein
interessantes also über zwei Dinge
müssen wir sprechen das eine ist Chicco
ist gerade schon gefallen
besser bekannt als Chicco die Geschichte
eines Mannes aus Dortmund
Knast gesessen drogenabhängig und
gewinnt dann plötzlich im Jackpot die
ganz große Kohle und erzählt von diesem
unfassbaren Moment wie er hört ein Mann
in Dortmund hat den Jackpot geknackt und
er geht zu seinem zu seinem Kiosk da
schein rein und es macht Ding und der
Mann ist eher
9,9 Millionen ist das nicht eine
großartige Geschichte das ist wunderbare
Geschichte ja der fällt mir gut und dann
zumal den Richtigen getroffen hat genau
und dann fängt er an über dieses Geld
und diesen mega Gewinn zu erzählen und
zwar in so ziemlich allen deutschen
Zeitungen die es gibt und ich habe
gedacht das ist so das erfrischendste im
Umgang mit Geld was ich seit langer Zeit
gehört habe jeder erzählen wie viel man
hat ja und was ich natürlich sehr leicht
zum Opfer dadurch
gerade so lange weil die alten Freunde
die er so hatte und die Welt in der sich
so bewegt und so weiter ne wir müssen ja
zwei starke Gefühle in ihm gewesen sein
einmal dieser unendliche stolz dass er
ist über diesen Weg geschafft hat und
das auch zu zeigen und das jeden wissen
zu lassen in seiner Freude und auf der
anderen Seite ständig damit zu rechnen
dass er einen auf die Muskel kriegt ja
genau sagt das auch ne ich muss jetzt
dauernd aufpassen wenn ich unterwegs bin
weil in der Kneipe schmeißen sie dir was
ins Glas raumtücher aus oder neben dir
deine Ruhe weg und dachte ich auch
irgendwie und meine ganz neuer Blick
aufs Leben also ich die Sorge hatte ich
so jetzt nie in der erzählt haben wir
dann mit seinem mit seinem Porsche mit
seinem Ferrari erst mal 100 mal die
Straße hoch und runter gefahren ist nur
um zu zeigen ich habe es geschafft ich
bin kein Fake Millionär das großartig
absolut das ist das was ist das teuerste
was du dir gekauft hast
das teuerste du meinst jetzt irgendwie
als also
Gegenstand oder so praktische Dinge wie
eine Wohnung nein ich meine nee nee nee
eine Wohnung ist ja schon wieder
vernünftig ja das ist ja schon wieder
gemeinsam sozusagen wo ich
unverhältnisse gehauen genau
ist ja nicht so richtig meine Mentalität
du weißt ja ich war kein Auto ich sehe
mit einer dicken Uhr im Zweifelsfall
peinlich aus außerdem finde ich die
schönsten Uhren sind keine besonders
protzigen stimmt
ja ich habe also irgendwie diese diese
materiellen Laster sind mir ein bisschen
fremden die sind mehr als Kind nicht in
die Wiege gelegt worden und das hat sich
auch nicht verändert ja also ich habe
schon mal sehr teure alte Bücher gekauft
zum Beispiel ich habe ja eine größere
Bibliothek an an alten Büchern
Philosophie und Naturgeschichte also
wirklich
verhältnismäßig viel ja so 17 bis 18
Jahrhundert oder so schön ziemlich teuer
sind Bill Gates hat auch eine
beeindruckende Buchsammlung
ja ja wahrscheinlich gibt es nichts was
er nicht hat ja aber es ist ja schon
immer interessant worauf die Leute dann
den Fokus legen ne
ich weiß noch ich hatte immer so die
Idee nicht mein mein Vater aber ich fünf
oder sechs mein Vater mein Papa weil LKW
fahre und er hat sich immer wahnsinnig
begeistern können für Autos und
irgendwann kam dann so die die ersten
deutschen Touristen zu uns dann auf dem
Berg und ins Tal und dann stand da
plötzlich der erste Porsche meines
Lebens ich habe den ersten Porsche
meines Lebens gesehen sondern Alter 911
war und ich habe die Faszination meines
Vaters für dieses Auto gesehen und
dachte immer okay irgendwann werde ich
ihn stolz machen irgendwann kaufe ich
mir mal so ein Porsche war für uns
völlig unerreichbar aber ich habe
gedacht irgendwann mache ich das und das
interessante war ich ich habe diesen
Traum nie aus dem aus dem Kopf verloren
und als ich dann so 30 war hätte ich das
erste Mal das Geld gehabt mit dem
Porsche zu kaufen und ab da hat er mich
interessanterweise nicht mehr
interessieren ja ich glaube da sagst du
was ganz wahres weil wenn ich jetzt
ernsthaft über deine Frage nachdenke da
muss man ja gucken
unverhältnismäßig viel Geld ausgegeben
in meinem Ergebnis zu dem was man hat
und da habe ich am meisten Geld
ausgegeben als ich am wenigsten hatte ja
also als ich Anfang 30 war habe ich mir
zwei Romeo Geli Anzüge gekauft ja ich
glaube die ich glaube die Marke gibt es
nicht mehr also ist mir jedenfalls nie
wieder untergekommen und das eine war so
aus einer aufgerauten Baumwolle was ein
bisschen außer wie Samt aber besser und
da habe ich mir so einen Dreiteiler mit
Weste gekauft und ich fand mich
unbeschreiblich großartig in das sind
man konnte noch nicht mal die Farbe
definieren irgendwas zwischen grau blau
und grün leer und dann in dieser
aufgerauten Baumwolle ich habe diesen
Anzug in dieser Zeit das war die Zeit in
meinem Arbeitslosigkeit jeden Tag
getragen
da konnte man also nach kilopreisen ja
kostet 4 Kilo kostet 5 Mark wie im Ernst
jetzt wieder also
mal locker locker 5 Hemden für fünf Mark
und das war natürlich so so Händen die
jetzt nicht mehr der aktuellen Mode in
Sprachen sondern der vor 10 oder 20
Jahren und die habe ich getragen also
diese weißen Hemden unter diesen drei
Eier ne ja und danach habe ich mir noch
einen einen Anzug den habe ich auch noch
von Romeo und Juli gekauft ich habe den
einfach nicht passt nicht mehr rein ne
ich habe also damals locker 15 kg
weniger gewogen als heute
und deswegen kann ich hier nicht
vertragen das größte 50 und der ist so
weiß und ist so grün blau gestreift und
damit bin ich früher immer in
erfolglosen Zeiten auf die Buchmesse
gefahren um auffällig zu sein ich weiß
nur zu mir gesagt hat wie kann man sowas
anziehen ich sag dir fällt in der Anzug
nicht und sagte nicht auf der Buchmesse
am Strand von Rimini vielleicht
ja aber ich meine das interessante war
in dem Moment wo man kein Geld hat da
war man es sich wert und da war es
wichtig unverhältnismäßig viel Geld für
Dinge auszugeben an denen man sich dann
so festgehalten hat um seine Würde zu
bewahren ich würde mal so ausdrücken
Punkt und in dem Moment als das Geld
mehr wurde wurden diese Status Käufe und
wichtiger ähnlich wie das mit deinem
Porsche ist ja tatsächlich ja ich nehme
es will nicht ich bin ich ich kann mit
diesen night Debatten nie was anfangen
ne wenn dann wenn dann so gelästert wird
über den Porsche Fahrer Christian
Lindner und so weiter
lass es doch einfach wenn wenn Menschen
bereit sind 150 200 000 € für ein Auto
auszugeben dann sehe ich eigentlich
immer die Leute dahinter die die dort am
Band stehen die Ingenieure wie viele
Menschen haben Arbeit weil ein anderer
bereit ist 200.000 € für ein Auto
auszugeben lass ihn doch wenn er das
Geld zurück in die in den Kreislauf
bringt und wenn es idealerweise ein Auto
ist das kann CO2 produziert ist doch
alles gut warum muss man diese diese
diese diese
Gegenpole immer aufmachen ne diese diese
Position so gegeneinander stellen
also das der Vorbehalt wäre zu sagen
warum ist dem
Finanzminister Status so wichtig und er
würde wahrscheinlich
wichtig sondern er nimmt diese Autos ja
genau und es ist auch völlig in Ordnung
so wie ich zum Beispiel Kameras liebe
ich habe schon sehr viel Geld für
Kameras ausgegeben ist etwas oder
objektive ja es gibt so Objektive
auch wenn man sich wenn man richtig
guter Fotograf sein will unumgänglich
also die muss man haben wenn man diesen
Hobby frönt oder dieser Leidenschaft
oder ist ja bei mir nicht einfach nur
ein hobbing also es ist ja sowieso
zweiter Beruf ja genau also damit dann
ist das berufsausrüstung dann braucht
man das ja aber
es gibt ja genau es gibt ja Objektive
die zum Beispiel lichtstärker sind als
das menschliche Auge
ja also die die die Güte eines guten
Objektivs wird gemessen so in der Frage
wie viel Licht lässt das Ding durch und
eins zu eins wäre sozusagen so
lichtstark wie das menschliche Auge
müsste Referenzpunkt es gibt Objektive
die haben 0,95 sind lichtstärker ist das
menschliche Auge das bedeutet aber auch
was die Tiefenschärfe
unglaublich kurz wird das heißt er kann
es dann anfangen Fotos zu machen wo du
wirklich nur die Wimpern so ein ganz
bisschen in die Schärfe ziehst und der
ganze Rest verschwindet dann schon
wieder so unter uns Schärfe so
wunderschöne Effekte erzählen und
natürlich kannst du auch fotografieren
wenn es dann ziemlich düster und dunkel
ist aber es geht vor allen Dingen um
diesen und diese extrem kurze
Tiefenschärfe und das ist halt so
wunderschön und ich sehe das dann das
hat sowas Stehtisches genauso wie auch
so ein schöner Porsche was machen sie
nicht ästhetisches hat und deswegen
sollte man den Leuten die Freude daran
finde ich nicht nehmen ich frage mich
nur Richard jetzt mal
soziologisch philosophisch betrachtet
und du kennst Frank Augustin ja der
Chefredakteur von von agorats 42
philosophisch ist Wirtschaftsmagazin ein
tolles Magazin übrigens finde ich sehr
großartig ja so die Jungs haben mich
damals besucht und ich habe mich dann
damals angeboten da in den
herausgeberstadt zu gehen Beirat und das
großartige ist also hier wird auf besten
Niveau und da gibt's ja auch tolle
Autoren die dafür schreiben Wirtschaft
und Philosophie zusammengebracht das ist
ja das was eigentlich viel zu wenig
passiert und das gibt's jetzt seit weit
über 10 Jahren und ich kenne nichts
vergleichbares was du gut ist in diesem
Bereich super so und von Frank Augustin
stammt der schöne Satz eine Gesellschaft
die sich zu sehr um Geld und dessen
Vermehrung dreht
irgendwann durch ja
und das ist ein bisschen doch auch die
Georg Simmel Theorie
der berühmte Soziologe der ja diese
Standardwerk zum Thema Geld dafür
Philosophie des Geldes genau ganz
berühmtes Buch ganz dickes Buch genau
also Georg Simmel ist einer der Erfinder
der Soziologie in der Zeit als die
Soziologie so überhaupt in den Rang
einer Wissenschaft kam ein wunderbares
Ziel ist ja nicht einfach zu lesen nee
aber aber sehr ästhetische Sätze und er
bringt sozusagen die Ausleuchtung der
Gefühle und Mentalitäten des Menschen
mit rationalen Strukturen zusammen also
ich Philosophen versuchen alles rational
zu erklären ne und er versucht eben auch
die Gefühle mit einzubeziehen
auszuleuchten und der widmet sich diesem
Thema Geld von allen erdenklichen Seiten
ja also alles was einem dazu einfällt
und versucht es irgendwie in der Theorie
zu bringen und es gibt zwei wichtige
Erkenntnisse von Simmel die einige ist
klingt negativ und die andere positiv
die negative ist Geld nichtet Moral
ja und die positive lautet Geld
demokratisiert
und zwar in dem es Moral nichtet oder
sind die Erklärung ist folgendermaßen
früher haben die Leute in ihren eigenen
Welten gelebt und das heißt Katholiken
in ihrer katholischen Welt und die
Protestanten in ihrer protestantischen
Welt und verschiedene Kulturen und so
weiter man hat nur sehr begrenzt
miteinander gehandelt ich meine jetzt
mit diesem früher ist die Welt vor der
ersten industriellen Revolution vor dem
Freihandel und so weiter das heißt also
Status später eine unglaubliche Rolle
Ehre Klassenzugehörigkeit Religion das
waren die ganz wichtigen Dinge und
Wirtschaft war immer in dieses
gesellschaftliche Korsett eingebettet
und dadurch dass die Finanzwirtschaft
sich immer weiter emanzipierte vor allem
durch die Erfindung des Papiergeldes
oder der Schuldscheine und was das alles
gab der Wechsel in diesem Moment kann
praktisch jeder mit jedem Handel treiben
egal in welchem Land er ist woran er
glaubt welche gesellschaftlichen
Geschichte angehört und so weiter das
heißt also jetzt passieren zwei Dinge
alles das worüber man sich vorher
definiert hat so der eigene wertekosmos
der wird immer unbedeutender weil die
Geldwerte ersetzen die sozialen Werte
das ist dieses Nichten von Moral weißt
du vor dem Geld sind alle gleich ist
richtig das Geld hat nur ein Maßstab ja
und zwar keinen
qualitativen sondern nur ein quantitativ
ja viel und wenig also Geld ist die
einzige Sache der Welt deren Qualität
sich allein an der Quantität bemisst und
damit ist es genuin unmoralisch beim
Moral bedeutet ja immer qualitativ zu
werden was ist richtig was ist falsch
was es höre eigentlich niedrig was
achtet man was echtet man das Geld kennt
das alles nicht das Geld machen
miteinander vergleichbares armoralisch
genau es ist ohne
moralfrei genau aber dadurch können
überhaupt erst demokratische
gesellschaftschaften entstehen weil in
diesen demokratischen Gesellschaft ja
vor dem Gesetz ist ja auch jeder gleich
genauso wie hier vor dem Geld jeder
gleich ist diese Entwicklung ist
parallel also etwas entstehen des
Geldsystems des modernen und die
Entstehung der bürgerlichen
Gesellschaften geht Hand in Hand
und dadurch dass man mit jedem
potenziell irgendwo handeln kann wird
vor dem Geld ja jeder auf die gleiche
Stufe gestellt ja uns wird jetzt nicht
mehr gesagt ja aber Moment ich bin
höheren Standes oder niederen Standes
oder
überlegenen Kultur an oder ich echte
deine Kultur spielt hier alles vor dem
Geld keine Rolle und deswegen einerseits
wird die Moral die nichtet durch die
Amoralität des Geldes und auf der
anderen Seite wird die Gesellschaft
demokratisiert indem die Klassen und
sozialen Schranken aufgehoben werden
genau nur viel und wenig akzeptiert wird
aber sonst man keine Privilegien mehr
hat er ist interessant ich meine das ist
exakt das was du da gerade beschreibst
was junger Mann Gold ne schöne Grüße der
der erfüllt ist derzeit ist ein
wahnsinnig interessanter Denker finde
ich ein toller Schreiber der hat ein
Buch gemacht die Orange Pille glaube ich
heißt das ähm Unterzeile warum Bitcoin
mehr ist als nur neues Geld
wo er sozusagen die Idee von von Bitcoin
beschreibt und so weiter und sagt das
ist
limitiert auf glaube ich 21.000 Stück
und so weiter können vielleicht gleich
noch meinen Satz darüber reden aber
interessant ist er sagt es ist kein
Zufall dass die Geldwirtschaft
aufgekommen ist als die alte feudale
Gesellschaft unterging
an die Stelle der Herkunft ja dadurch
untergegangen also das ist die zentrale
simmelthese die Geldwirtschaft hat der
Adelsgesellschaft des Genick gebrochen
ja also was nützt es dir über
standesprivilegien einen tausend Jahre
alten Stammbaum und so weiter zur
Verfügung wenn du nicht genug Kohle hast
ja und wenn das Geld immer wichtiger
wird und auch durch den Freihandel immer
unbegrenzter vermehrt werden kann und so
weiter dann fallen die anhalten
Privilegien weg
genau und damit ist die alles
Gesellschaft dauerhaft nicht mehr
aufrecht zu erhalten außerdem besonders
mehr als Adliger du bist als selfmade
Millionär in der Gesellschaft mehr wert
als als verarmte artiger richtig also im
Grunde kommen mit dem Geld quasi die
aufstiegsgeschichten absolut und damit
wird die ganze Gesellschaft keine
valisiert ja das ist die ganze alte
Ordnung geht nicht mehr als das wird
unmaskiert ja die Werte werden
ungewertet und es entsteht die
bürgerliche Gesellschaft und für die
bürgerliche Gesellschaft ist die
Geldwirtschaft quasi sowas wie DNA
dass er total interessant nur wenn du
das erlebt man ja auch häufig also da
wird dann so die Nase gerümpft also
altes Geld rümpft die Nase über
sogenanntes neues Geld zu der parmenü
die Aufsteiger die neue reichen der muss
ja nicht denken nur weil er jetzt mal
und so weiter genau und dann setzt man
sich quasi ab von diesem neureichen
Pöbel ja indem man sagt aber wir sind ja
das alte Geld sowas
exakt als wäre das etwas besser
Dürre ja wie die Kennedys oder so wenn
etwas waren die Alkohol Schmuggler ja
und der ist in miese Geschäfte gemacht
wird ja und dann sich quasi
reingewaschen indem die Kinder in der
Politik Karriere gemacht haben und so
weiter und nach einigen Jahrzehnten ja
es werden aus den den Verbrecher
Biografien ja werden da irgendwie
spannende pioniergeschichten oder so
also ich meine viele von den von dem
berühmten großen Geldhäusern und
Dynastien und so weiter die haben auch
mal etwas ganz anders angefangen
diejenigen die wieder genauso anfangen
wie sie richtig ja genau damit wollen
wir nichts mehr zu tun haben
du ich habe neulich eine Zahl gelesen
ich weiß nicht ob die so wirklich
verifizierbar ist und und und wirklich
stimmt aber ich glaube in der Tendenz
stimmt es wenn du Gesellschaften
vergleichst wenn du zum Beispiel die USA
dir anschaust versus Deutschland ja
findest miteinander vergleichst was
dieses Thema angeht dann hast du
zumindest gefühlt in den USA heute eine
Struktur wo du sagen musst 9 der 10
reichsten Amerikaner sind Gründer und 9
der 10 reichsten Deutschen sind Erben
ja also wirklich altes Geld neues Geld
das ist eine gute Zahl die ist spannend
ja total spannend ne weil viel über eine
Gesellschaft aus das meine ich ja und
weil es auch zeigen wahrscheinlich auch
Gründer sein ja genau
China nicht aber schwierig Millionär zu
werden in mauszeiten also da wirst du es
ähnlich haben also du hast ja die sind
ein guter Indikator für
aufsteigergesellschaften und obwohl die
USA ja nicht mehr eine
pioniergesellschaft sind
die China ist es immer noch interessant
dass der Gründer und Pioniergeist so
stark ist ja also das heißt auch die
Möglichkeit die aus diesem großen Geld
erwächst ne ja also das sagt ja auch
Mangold junger Mangold sagt das auch er
sagt ich glaube also er sagt wir wir
reden über Geld immer als wäre das sowas
negatives Rumpf mit den Nasen Geld alle
hetzen und hecheln der Kohle hinterher
aber keiner will offiziell was damit zu
tun haben weil wir so das Gefühl haben
dass das Trigger zu diese ganzen
Instinkte so die hier und den Geist und
Neid und so weiter das ist auch alles
nicht ganz falsch auch eine Seite des
ganzen genau aber er sagt ich glaube das
Geld das Beste aus den Menschen holt
weil es Kreativität
Innovationskraft
Dialogfähigkeit und so weiter auch aus
ihnen herausholt man so ein wunderbarer
Charakter wie Carsten Maschmeyer
also ich würde dich würde diese These
mal nicht übertreiben ja es würde sagen
das Geld hat auch seine guten Seiten
aber jetzt den große loblief so machen
nach dem Motto Geld macht gut geht mir
vielleicht ein bisschen zu weit ja
Simmel geht ja auch eine ähnliche
Richtung ne der sagt also sein Geld ist
jetzt nicht nur Mittel zum Zweck sondern
irgendwann haben wir angefangen dieses
Geld quasi zu einem echten Selbstwert zu
machen in den Start in den Status einer
Gottheit quasi zu erheben so drückt er
sich glaube ich auch aus ja ja das ist
so also eigentlich es geht mit Geld ja
Mittel wenn ich jetzt aber weiß wie ich
in meinem Bereich mein Geld immer mehr
und mehr vermehren kann dann wird die
geldformierung zum Zweck an sich ich
denke also nicht mehr über das Ziel nach
was ich damit erreiche sondern ich mache
nur noch drehe nur noch die Spirale des
Meer immer weiter
und dann kommt irgendwann am Ende eine
Mentalität bei sehr vielen Leuten mit
sehr viel Geld dabei raus dass sie
eigentlich kein Ziel in dem Sinne mehr
haben ja also einmal weißt du alle
Menschen sind käuflich also es ist nur
eine Frage wie viel man ihnen anbietet
wie das der Frage des Preises genau was
hilft wenn Geld nicht hilft mehr Geld ja
also sozusagen die eine Weisheit dadurch
kann man sehr leicht zum Zyniker werden
ist nicht so einfach noch an die wahre
Liebe zu glauben und an gute
Freundschaft und so weiter wenn man das
finalisiert hat und das andere ist du
findest nie ein Ziel wo du sagst doch
das habe ich jetzt alles erreicht ja
jetzt konzentriere ich mich mal auf all
die anderen Seiten im Leben sondern wenn
das Geld so stark deine Psyche
beherrscht ja dann beherrscht du das
nicht mehr das beherrscht dich dieser
Mechanismus ist mehr und mehr und mehr
und dann kannst du dich an dem
Erreichten auch meistens dann nicht mehr
freuen weil du denkst jetzt noch mehr
erreichen können und kannst du noch mehr
machen max hat man schönen Satz dazu
gesagt ja vom Kapitalisten der einem
Welten Entdecker gleich der mit jedem
vorgefunden und Kontinent nur eine neue
Grenze entdeckt
ja das heißt also bis nie zufrieden mit
dem was du hast sondern gehst mit wieder
dann über die nächste Grenze wieder auf
der einen Seite ist das ein zentraler
Motor der Wirtschaft in kapitalistischen
Ländern und ein eine der Grundlagen des
Reichtums und auf der anderen Seite ist
es irgendwie auch eine Pathologie ja
oder ich also meine gestört ja genau
aber die Frage ist sicher würdest du zu
dieser These zustimmen ich nicht also
ich habe nicht das Gefühl dass das
sozusagen mehr Geld zu verdienen
erfolgreicher zu sein dass das am Ende
immer neue Unzufriedenheit produziert
sondern dass das gute Gefühl ist doch
eigentlich dass du die irgendwann den
Luxus erlauben kannst und das ist für
mich der Luxus von von Geld dass du
nicht mehr darüber nachdenken musst
sondern dass er sie ihr Geldautomat und
ja noch größer ich weiß es noch größer
die damit einhergehende Freiheit ja
genau selbst bestimmt teilt die meisten
Menschen können ihrem Chef nicht ihre
Meinung sein
ja hätten sie Millionen auf dem Konto
könnten sie das dann werden genau ja
genau aber ich muss ja in meinem ganz
normalen lebens-alltag immer gucken auf
jeden muss ich Rücksicht nehmen was kann
ich nicht machen und so weiter mit der
Sicherheit jetzt im Arbeitsverhältnis
nicht mehr angewiesen zu sein und so
weiter das befreit das gibt einem eine
Souveränität die man sonst im Leben
nicht haben kann wo man also gezwungen
ist auch mit Leuten die man nicht leiden
kann soziales Schach zu spielen und so
weiter weil man kann ja nicht und am
Ende verliere ich noch hier und meine
Arbeit und man ist in so einem Gefüge
drin indem man nie ganz frei sein kann
und das ist natürlich mit der Sicherheit
des Geldes erhöht sich der Freiheitsgrad
absolut und das ist uneingeschränkt
positiv ja ich
meine redet ja so häufig darüber warum
es eigentlich im Leben geht und wenn du
ein Büchereien rein gehst dann findest
du ja meterweise
Regale mit mit glücksradgebern 80% davon
von Eckert von Hirschhausen und unter
Rest dann noch schon ein paar anderen
die die erklären sozusagen wie du zu
einem glücklichen Menschen wirst ich ich
war da immer sehr misstrauisch ich
dachte immer Glück ist doch in Wahrheit
ein so wahnsinnig flüchtiger Zustand
worum geht es eigentlich wirklich ich
glaube wir alle sehnen uns nach
Glücksmoment natürlich erleben wir die
hoffentlich auch aber die sind in der
nächsten Sekunde schon wieder vorbei und
das müssen sie auch sein weil Glück
empfindest du nur sozusagen im kontra
weil es im Kontrast genau weil es auch
ein Abwesenheit wenn man dauerhaft
glücklich ist fängt man an zu verblöten
so genau also das kann man nur unter
Drogen Einfluss oder sowas oder wenn man
verliebt ist oder so dass man so lange
Phasen hat wo man auf Wolke Sieben
schwebt und das wird meistens mit einem
Mangel an Realität sind bezahlt ja genau
also von Natur aus nicht für dauerhaftes
Glück ausgerichtet oder wie Wittgenstein
gesagt hat nein niemand weiß warum wir
auf der Erde sind aber bestimmt nicht
unglücklich zu sein ja ich ich denke mal
weißt du wenn du jeden Kaviar hast ja
dann ist halt irgendwann das Butterbrot
diessentation so einfach ist das aber da
sind wir wieder bei der Sache mit der
Grenze genau da sind wir dabei also
Mensch für Menschen werden ja werden ja
Dinge in unglaublichem Geschwindigkeit
alltäglich also man kauft sich ein Auto
was man unbedingt hat haben wollen ganz
ganz toll findet und wenn man das erste
Mal darin fährt und so weiter ist es ein
ganz großer Moment wenn du jahrelang mit
dem Auto gefahren bist was ich jeden Tag
mit zur Arbeit dann ist er nach sieben
Jahren Null großer Moment noch damit
verbunden ist schon sieben Tagen nicht
mehr eigentlich ja das Auto hat sich
auch schon fast halbiert
hat sich schon fast halbiert ja das ist
so aber davon leben unsere Gesellschaft
und man stelle sich mal vor du kaufst
dir die paar Dinge die du immer schon
wahnsinnig schön und toll kannst und
dann bist du dauerhaft dein Leben damit
glücklich da würde unsere Wirtschaft
zusammenbrechen also die notorische
Unzufriedenheit und die Flüchtigkeit des
Glücks sind die wichtigste Garantie in
kapitalistischen zu Ländern das ist
weitergeht genau aber was ich eigentlich
meinte ist solche geht es nicht im Bad
um was anderes geht es nicht darum und
das hat wiederum ganz eng was mit Geld
zu tun
Selbstbestimmtheit ich denke oft das ist
der beste Zustand den man als Mensch
erreichen kann und ich würde sagen du
bist in einem solchen Zustand hast das
Glück gehabt ich habe das definitiv auch
und ich empfinde das als wahnsinniges
Privileg dass ich genau vorhin Freiheit
gesagt nee aber selbstbestimmter das ist
auch ein guter Begriff dafür ja also
Markus da hast du absolut Recht also
dieses Gefühl selbst bestimmt sein zu
können frei sein zu können
sich nicht ständig in Abhängigkeiten
bewegen zu müssen und so weiter mein
Leben ja auch nicht in einem Leben
völlig unabhängigkeiten aber nein es hat
sich natürlich massiv geändert als jetzt
in der Zeit wo man auf alles Rücksicht
nehmen musste aufpassen musste mit allem
was man tat und so weiter also diese
Freiheit die ist in ganz großes Privileg
ja finde ich auch und umgekehrt Geld
sozusagen als selbstweg ich du hast doch
auch bestimmt häufig mit Menschen zu tun
die die auf eine nicht mehr greifbare
Art und Weise reich sind nicht häufig
aber sowas trifft man solche Menschen
die die unvorstellbar Milliardäre kennst
du wieder der persönlich
und ist das ein glücklicher Mensch oder
ich würde sagen ja aber wie ich vorhin
an dem Beispiel der Kurve gesagt hat du
bist natürlich als Milliardär nicht
tausendmal glücklicher als als Millionär
und als Millionär nicht tausendmal
glücklicher als wenn du ganz wenig Geld
hast also dass das steigt natürlich
nicht in dem gleichen Ausmaß aber der
würde auch sagen Freiheit und selbst
Bestimmtheit
unabhängiges Leben zu führen die Frage
ist Richard was würde passieren wenn wir
und das ist ja sozusagen der Kontrast
dazu ja also der die Kritik am Geld ist
ja immer das fördert wahnsinnig
Ungerechtigkeit und die Schere geht
immer weiter auseinander und da gibt es
diese dieses eine Prozent das obstsöhnen
Reich ist ja das ist ein Teil was 80 90
Prozent ist Reichtums eines Landes du
besitzt und der ganze Rassismus
irgendwie gucken wie er zurecht kommt ja
und da reden wir nicht nur von von einem
Land wie Russland da reden wir auch von
den von einer alten Demokratie wieder in
den USA z.B sehr sehr interessant
richtig
genau meine Frage wäre wäre es besser
wäre es wirklich besser wenn alle gleich
werden wenn alle gleich viel Geld hätten
ja aber das oder wäre das ganz komisch
war alle gleich die Anzahl der Menschen
die sich das wünschen ist sehr
überschaubar also spätestens wenn das
realisiert wäre
aber jetzt mal die Sache ist doch wir
haben doch nicht nur die Alternative
zwischen A und B also wir haben ja nicht
nur die Alternative das irgendwie 10%
der Weltbevölkerung letztlich alle
Ressourcen alles Geld dieser Welt
gehören und dem Rest gehört der Rest
also
das ist ja nicht die Alternative sondern
die Frage ist wenn die
Einkommensverhältnisse in einem Land
sehr sehr stark auseinandergeht wie das
so bei Schwellenländern
Entwicklungsländern und so weiter der
Fall ist aber leider zunehmend auch bei
den etablierten die Wahlen Demokratien
dann wächst das Gefühl eines großen
Teils der Bevölkerung das ist hier nicht
mit rechten Dingen zugeht und das kann
man ihnen auch nicht denken dass das so
ist das heißt also der soziale Unfrieden
wird damit geschürt die stabilsten
Länder sind Länder mit einer sehr
breiten Mittelschicht skandinavischen
Länder zum Beispiel oder Luxemburg oder
so also das ist für jedes Land ist das
eine Zeitbombe wenn die
Einkommensverhältnisse zu stark
auseinander gehen und zweitens wenn die
Aufstiegschancen ja wenn die nachlassen
und aus Geld Geld zu machen also wenn
Millionen oder Milliarden geerbt hat die
zu vermehren dafür braucht man nicht mal
schlau sein ja da hat man ein paar
clevere Finanzverwalter die man trauen
kann ja und dann wird das entsprechend
investiert und dann wird ganz ganz
schnell aus viel Geld noch viel mehr
genau aber wenn du von unten kaum noch
Chancen hast irgendwie auf die Füße zu
kommen überhaupt in die Mittelschicht
reinzukommen und das alles ereignet sich
gleichzeitig in einem Land in dem die
einen ihr Geld spielen vermehren und die
anderen kaum noch zu welchem kommen dann
hat dieses Land ein riesiges Problem
und das ist die Situation in die wir
reinschlägt an das hat gar nichts mit
Neid oder sowas zu tun sondern da muss
man sich viele Gedanken darüber machen
wie man Steuersystem zum Beispiel ändert
dass das nicht auf die Art und Weise so
weitergeht und du weißt ja genau wenn
ich rede von Steuersystem ändern dann
meine ich nicht dass man eine
unbegrenzte Einkommenssteuer nach oben
macht dass man wenn du 100%
Einkommensteuer sein sondern es war
Finanztransaktion Mann das besteuert das
wäre schon mal ein sehr gutes Mittel
dagegen sind
Interesse Haltung reichen gegenüber die
vielen Gesellschaften da ist in der
deutschen Gesellschaft da ist die z.B
auch sehr interessante auch in der
italienischen Gesellschaft sehr
ausgeprägtes gibt's interessante
Untersuchungen dazu Amerika eher weniger
aber so dieser das was man so klassisch
sozialen Einheit nennt das das gibt es
und das ist ja auch steuerpolitisch dann
von Belang ne
ist aber ein Land voller Widersprüche
mittlerweile ne man könnte in eine ganze
Folge könnten wir nur machen über die
über die die Kriminalität die Gang
Kriminalität die mittlerweile in
Schweden da ist die auch unter anderem
dazu geführt hat dass dass diese sehr
rechten Schweden Demokraten dort
mittlerweile das Ruder übernommen haben
in der Regierung das ist ja ein eine 180
Grad wollte die da hingelegt haben so
dieses dieses
abgebrannt wird dann immer gesagt
interessant ist du hast gerade gesagt
die skandinavischen Länder sind
sozusagen das Paradebeispiel für für
diese für diese ja für diese diese
korrigiere ich mich und sagen waren es
zumindestens also für für gute
Einkommensverteilung wobei Schweden
immer das Brutalste Land war also in den
Schweden ist der ja am Reich Kontrast
immer deutlich stärker gewesen als in
Norwegen ist genau genau und in in den
was haben wir doch immer gehört also in
den 80er 90er Jahren 90er Jahren wurden
in Schweden reich Menschen extrem hoch
bescheuert was ja auch dazu
zwei Prozent Steuern zahlen das erinnere
ich mich noch
ich erinnere mich noch an Ingwer
kampradin ikea-gründer der ist ja dann
abgehauen der hatte keinen Bock mehr der
ist glaube ich ne irgendwo auf jeden
Fall ich glaube entdeckte plötzlich
seine Liebe zu den Schweizer Bergen aber
was interessant ist und und da glaube
ich ist schon eine Quelle für für so ein
Frust den es in vielen westlichen
Gesellschaften mittlerweile gibt dieses
vom Gefühl her doch eher gerechte Land
Schweden hat dann auch und da siehst du
wie die Reichen ist dann doch immer
wieder schaffen sozusagen ihr Spiel zu
spielen sein Steuersystem immer weiter
reformiert ja Einkommensteuer und so
weiter die die die die die das wurde
immer weiter abgesenkt dann wurde die
Vermögenssteuer wurde abgeschafft
Erbschaftssteuer wurde komplett
abgeschafft und so weiter das heißt
dieses
Schweden von dem wir immer sagen das ist
eigentlich das Ideal so sollte es
eigentlich sein weil sehr gerecht
verteilt auch dieses Schweden ist
unbemerkt von der großen Öffentlichkeit
in den letzten Jahren vor allen Dingen
immer ungerechter und immer ungleicher
geworden wenn man so will und und da
denke ich manchmal
warum warum geht da keiner dagegen warum
warum lässt man diese Entwicklungen dann
einfach so laufen wenn man doch die
warnenden Beispiele aus anderen Ländern
England zum Beispiel Großbritannien
wahnsinnig ungerecht das Land was das
angeht wenn man es Frankreich ungerechte
Vermögensverteilung enorm hoher steuern
so ja also auch irgendwas was überhaupt
nicht funktioniert ne und dann hast du
dann eine wachsende Zahl von abgehängten
und dass das Schlimmste was sie überall
demokratischen Gesellschaft passieren
kann ja ist eine sehr große Zahl von
abgehängten oder sich abgehängt
fühlenden ja das ist die größte Wohnung
aber ich möchte noch auf einen Aspekt
gerne kommen zum Thema Geld weil die
letzte Frage ob man jetzt neidisch ist
ob man was gerecht findet und was
ungerecht findet ob man was rechtfertigt
hängt ja eigentlich immer vom Fairness
Maßstab ab ja ist also immer immer die
Frage welche Verhältnisse werden als
fair gesehen und welche als unfair und
dazu gibt es ja ein ganz interessantes
wirtschaftspsychologisches Spiel das
versucht zu ergründen wie das denn
eigentlich mit der menschlichen Fairness
oder Unfairness bestellt ist und dieses
Spiel hat ich habe ja eine Uni in Köln
studiert und da war Werner gut bei den
volkswirtschaftern hat 1978 ein Spiel
erfunden das heißt ultimatumspiel
und das ist das berühmteste Spiel der
Wirtschaftspsychologie
und das hat Werner güt jetzt erstmal gar
nicht abgesehen als er das Spiel
erfunden hat und das Spiel geht
folgendermaßen
man stelle sich eine Zeit vor in der 100
€ ein hoher Geldbetrag ist ja also es
gibt natürlich genug Menschen für die
ist das so für andere ist das nicht so
jetzt stellt sich jeder mal diese
Situation vor man hat sehr wenig Geld
und man kriegt 100 € geschenkt
die darf man behalten aber nur unter
einer Bedingung man muss sie mit jemand
anders Teilen der einem dazugelost wird
ja also irgendjemand einmal auf der
Straße begegnet oder ist ein großer Raum
da sitzen hunderte von Leuten drin und
sagst ja so jetzt kannst du deinem
Nachbarn ja ein Angebot machen wie Du
vorher hast die 100 € oft zu teilen so
das kriegt auch keiner mit das heißt ihr
geht mal kurz raus und dann machst du
den anderen Angebot dann kannst du dem
zu sagen pass mal auf 90 10 du darfst
nur einen Vorschlag machen das nicht
nachbessern ja nur ein geht der andere
auf den Vorschlag ein ja dann wird
genauso geteilt 90 10 70 30 50 50 wenn
der andere sagt westerchen du Arschloch
ja ist das denn für ein Scheiß
Überschlag ja dann krieg ich der
Spielleiter das Geld zurück okay was
glaubst du was der weltweit man hat das
den einen erdenklichen Kulturen gespielt
ja dieser ganz bedeutende berühmteste
Schweizer Ökonom ich glaube mittlerweile
berühmteste Ökonomen deutschsprachigen
Raum hat dieses diese ist Spiel
perfektioniert den allen möglichen
Varianten Schüler von ihm haben das in
der ganzen Welt gespielt das glaubst du
was der am häufigsten gemacht der
teilungsvorschlag ist
so gut ist der Mensch nicht schließlich
habe ich dir das Geld angeboten und
nicht dem anderen 60-40 okay also man
sollte ein Vorteil haben aber man
kalkuliert so hoch genau dass der andere
sich dann nun wirklich nicht drüber
beschweren kann ja genau so jetzt könnte
man sagen das ist ein unschlagbarer weiß
für die menschlichen Egoismus weil du
hast die 40 ja nur abgegeben können Sie
mal 1 € geben weil du weißt der nimmt 1
€ oder 10 € nicht an ja klar genau so
genau das ist aber kein eindeutiger
Beweis für den menschlichen Egoismus
weil interessant ist ja der andere wäre
der Mensch so ein kostenlosen kalkuliere
ja ein homo ökonomicus wie der in den
Lehrbücher hören der
wirtschaftsfakultäten ist dann würde der
auch 10 € nehmen
bei der müsste sicher sagen 10 oder 0 er
ist schon klar ja also er profitiert ja
noch bei 90 10 und die Erfahrung klärt
das Angebot mit 10 oder 20 Euro
zurückgewiesen werden aber warum weil in
dem Moment dem das Gefühl zu sehen wie
du deine 90 €, die Du schon in der
Tasche hast wieder Abdrücken musst mehr
wert ist als 10 € meinst du darum geht's
es geht um diesen Triumph in der Sekunde
es geht um den Triumph in der Sekunde
die die wir sind egoistische
kooperateure sagt er ja aber
altruistische Bestrafung okay das heißt
der die dich jetzt bestraft der hat ja
nichts davon dass er dich bestraft er
hat sogar Nachteile der hat die 10 €
nicht genau aber er hat das Gefühl der
Gerechtigkeit ist Genüge getan ja also
im Dienste der Allgemeinheit wird das
Arschloch bestraft das zu Egoist
so funktioniert die menschliche Moral
und das ist ja eine wunderschöne
Erklärung wir Fairness Regeln eigentlich
funktionieren wann denken wir an unseren
eigennutzt wenn wir genug abkriegen ja
und wann fangen wir an besonders fährt
zu werden wenn wir das Gefühl haben wir
haben zu wenig gekriegt und der
Allgemeinheit ist sozusagen ein
moralischer Schaden zugefügt so und
jetzt hat dieses Spiel einen Haken
und der ist mir irgendwann aufgefallen
ich habe früher das in Vorträgen häufig
erzählt zu dem Thema werden wir über
Millionäre und Milliardäre gesprochen
stell dir mal vor Markus es sind nicht
100 €, sondern es ist eine Million wäre
ja ja ja ja ja ja und jetzt teilst du
die eine Millionen auf du gehst mit dem
hinter die Tür und sag du kriegst
100.000 und ich 900.000 wer wird dann im
Dienste der Allgemeinheit sagen die
100.000 nehme ich nicht alles wieder ab
das heißt also ab einer bestimmten
Geldsumme ja singt unser Gefühl für das
Allgemeinwohl oder unser altruistischer
das heißt also Geld je nach Summe
verändert die Moral jedes einzelne total
weißt du was total interessant ist
übrigens gerade nachdenke die ganze Zeit
wenn du das erzählst drehst mal um also
du hast diese Million und du sagst ihm
pass auf ich gebe dir 900.000 ich bin
mit 100 zufrieden ja oder ich gebe dir
von den 100 €, ich gebe dir noch
aber was macht er dann nimmt er sie oder
sagt er das kann es nicht machen das ist
das ist nicht gerechtkommen nimm du
wenigstens 40
wie wäre es jetzt so den Podcast hören
würden wahrscheinlich am meisten von
sich sagen sie würden das sagen aber in
der realen Situation würden die
wenigstens sagen ich weiß die würden
denken du bist richtig ein guter Mensch
Schuldgefühle
mehr aber wenn das stimmt was du sagst
wenn wenn sozusagen und in dich glaube
zu Tiefs daran und nicht jetzt weil ich
es selber wäre sondern weil es auch
schon einen kleinen Kindern beobachten
kannst Menschen sind hochmoralische
Wesen auch kleines Kinder sind
hochmoralische Wesen ja solange man
nicht zu groß werden das ist ja meiner
Aussage ja ein moralinstinkt im Menschen
ja dieser Moral Instinkt ist kein Sinn
für Fairness auf der elementaren Ebene
die haben Menschen nicht aber Menschen
haben einen Sinn für Unfairness die ihn
wieder fährt und damit können sie ja
unter erzieherischer Begleitung so etwas
entwickeln wie ein Sinn für fernes
und das ist die gute Nachricht und die
schlechte Nachricht ist wenn Summen zu
groß werden ja dann schmilzt dieser Sinn
für fernes deswegen funktioniert
Bestechung eben auch so gut ja es ist
doch also normalerweise fällt Bestechung
nur dann auf ja oder wird wird sozusagen
der Gegend vorgegangen wenn die Summe
nicht groß genug ist also das größte
Fehler den ein Mensch machen kann der
ein beschicht ist eigentlich einsetzen
niedrig anzusetzen dann wird er einen
Pranger gestellt ja auch von dem der zu
niedrig gestochen ist weil er sich in
seinem Selbstwertgefühl nicht noch
geachtet
genau genau
Korruption stammt von Ashley brillant
einem englischen aphoristiker der gesagt
hat ich wünsche mir entweder das Ende
der Korruption oder mehr Möglichkeiten
davon zu profitieren
da passt Oskar dazu als ich klein war
glaubte ich Geld sei das wichtigste im
Leben heute da ich alt bin weiß ich es
stimmt
aber aber tatsächlich Alter Zyniker ich
ich weiß du was ich glaube in diese
Geschichte mit dem also du gibst dem
anderen sozusagen 90 und nimmst selber
zehn weißt du was ich glaube ich seine
Frage des Kontextes also wenn ich wenn
ich wüsste ich stehe jetzt jemandem
gegenüber der wirklich diese 90 € gut
gebrauchen kann ja und ich brauche sie
selber nicht ja dann dann wäre es doch
völlig normal das genauso zu machen ich
würde sogar behaupten ich würde es dann
auch so tun und ich glaube auch dass der
andere gar kein schlechtes Gefühl hätte
wenn das jemand ist der gerade in Not
ist natürlich wird er das Geld nehmen
ist doch gar keine Frage hey wenn ich
noch mal wenn ich jetzt jemanden was
Spende oder wenn ich sage immer du
kannst auch alles behalten ja weil er
mir leid hat dann fühle ich mich nachher
und dieses Gefühl sich edel zu fühlen
ist dann für mich mehr wert als 100 Euro
deswegen funktioniert das Spiel ja nur
unter der Bedingung dass diejenigen die
daran teilnehmen alle in der gleichen
sozialen Situation sagt genau das
funktioniert das Spiel der Kontext muss
genauso sein ja ja gar nicht vorstellen
die haben das Regenwald mit Indianern
gespielt und mit München im Tempel und
so weiter und ich kann mir immer
überhaupt nicht vorstellen was die Leute
gedacht haben weißt du das am besten
noch eine Filmkamera dabei und ein
großes Team und dann wird Team Geld in
die Hand gedrückt die zum Teil Kulturen
die gar nicht gar keine Geldwirtschaft
haben also ich wäre gern bei diesen
ganzen Experimenten dabei gewesen ich
glaube nur in Asien war das so dass die
tatsächlich mehr angeboten haben als sie
sich selbst gegeben haben jetzt könnte
man sagen ja der Asiate altruistisch
aber vielleicht haben Sie auch einfach
geglaubt das ist eine Falle
wunderbar also richard hat Spaß gemacht
aber
nur der eine Gedanke noch ne Geld wenn
du überlegst was Geld alles so
erleichtert ich stelle mir manchmal vor
in einer Zeit in der Menschen getauscht
haben da musst du ja erstmal sozusagen
den Gegenwert finden muss lange
unterwegs sein bis sozusagen der
Gegenwert passt sagt ich hätte gerne
einen Liter Milch was wiegt ein Liter
Milch auf und wie unvorstellbar einfach
ist es wenn du einfach sagen kannst guck
mal hier ist Geld hier ist anscheinend
hier ist eine Münze ja
so begründet der große englische
Philosoph John Lock ja die
Ungerechtigkeit die durch das Geld
entstanden ist er sagt die Menschen
lebten ursprünglich in einem
Naturzustand da hatte jeder das gleiche
und das war auch gleich so ja und dann
musste man um weiterzukommen tauschen
und solange man nur Naturalien tauschte
hatte man das große Problem eben was ist
ein equival hin und wo finde ich wie
lagere ich das ja ja ich habe das jetzt
hier gegen so ein Hirsch und es gab
keine Kühlschränke getauschte der ist
aber zu groß den kann ich jetzt nicht
essen und so weiter und deswegen haben
die Menschen das Geld eingeführt um aus
dem Dilemma der verderblichen Waren
herauszukommen super und dann seitdem
gibt es einen universell gültigen
geldvertrag dem haben auch alle
zugestimmt weil sie das sinnvoll fanden
ja und wenn du heute wenig hast soll ich
sagen deine Ahnen haben mal dem
geldvertrag zugestimmt super das heißt
Ungerechtigkeit im England des späten
Seite jahrhunderts verteidigt das heißt
man kann abschließend sagen vielleicht
ist das der finale Satz zu diesem Thema
geld verdirbt nicht wenn überhaupt nur
den Charakter so ist das großartig in
diesem Sinne mit diesem Aphorismus danke
sehr ja das hat Spaß gemacht tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]